Just a reminder to the married women that are miserable right now.
Divorce is an option. And it's not the end of the fucking world.
Matter of fact, that is it.
Not only is it not the end of the world,
it's probably the start of your new life.
A life that you never thought was possible.
A life that you kinda only dreamed of.
Because when you finally say,
fuck it, I don't care what people think about me,
I don't care what people say about me.
I can't do this anymore. I can't live like this anymore.
And you choose yourself. You realize how.
How small those voices are anyway.
They're just little whispers in the wind
while you're out there frolicking,
having the most fun of your life.
So if you're in a miserable marriage
and you think about divorce regularly,
go ahead and do it. You will not regret it.
The. The thing that you'll regret
is staying in that marriage longer than you wanted to
and giving him years and years and years that should have been yours.
So if you are on the fence,
if you're thinking about it,
I. I am living proof to tell you you can get out.
You can make it,
and you can be happier than you ever fucking dream possible.
I got four kids. One of them is disabled.
She's got congenital heart disease.
She's had four open heart surgeries.
If you want it bad enough, you can Get it